foreign
for you today oh good okay I'm glad yeah
it's called the initial digit problem oh
all righty yeah yeah never never heard
of it never heard of it okay so here it
goes ready go ahead so one of the great
challenges and needs of Science and
Technology and many other things in
society that you might not have known
about is the need to generate an
authentically random number
okay okay there are occasions where you
need a completely random number like a
pet like if you're generating a password
exactly exactly what is the the Dual the
secondary code that you need that's
we're told that that's random it's very
hard to produce a purely random number
it's extremely hard and if you step back
and you'd lay down enough of them you
say wait a minute I see a pattern there
and the pattern was the algorithm that
generated the random number and you can
often have it revealed in that way okay
there you go so uh what seems to be
totally random is when a radioactive
element decays within its cycling and so
there have been people who've tried to
attach a random number have that assign
the random number so just to let you
know that the depth to which we have
reached to establish pure Randomness in
a phenomenon or in an experiment that
we're conducting you might ask
why not just find numbers at random in
society
just open a book pick a number out there
you go why not open another book a
different book and there you have it
unread okay help close your eyes all
right park the book that's how I guess
okay just pick numbers randomly that
have been generated by civilization
if you do that
nearly a third of all those numbers will
begin with the numeral one
so they're not random
wow this is the famous initial digit
problem
so if you were to
truly on a random basis pick books
and randomly pick numbers
all those books books
by the way even page numbers even
pick any number that appears in anything
we created
ever
close your eyes and randomly pick okay
one third of those numbers nearly a
third of those numbers will begin with
the number one correct interesting so
they're not random that's right
they're not random oh okay
so so that that's an indication of
something okay because if you want uh
numbers let's say zero to nine
and you want to pick random you'd expect
each of those numbers to appear 10 of
the time right because they're 10 digits
ten digits zero zero through nine is ten
digits all right so sure
sure but but when we count things we
don't start at zero right we don't say
you're zero you're one no don't call me
zero right that's number one there was a
time when I that they did say that about
you yeah yeah all right all right quick
and sides Chuck but by the way zero is
one of the more important numbers ever
conceived so there you go maybe you
didn't know that at the time you say
thanks for the compliment right there
you go so take that Peter and Hakeem and
Jack screw you guys ah what's important
yeah right so
so watch how this works I mean it's
fascinating okay
if you start counting
all right so so let's do this if they're
just the digits there'd be a 10 chance
you should get a 9 or an eight or a
seven or a six okay if you're talking
about groups of ten
between one and a hundred
this should be a ten percent chance
you're in the 90s a 10 chance here in
the 80s right right 10 chance here in
the 70s if you're counting hundreds
there's a 10 chance you're in the
hundreds ten percent chance you're in
the 200s temperatures right
okay did that make sense makes sense
yeah okay so watch so let's do this
let's pull out
all two numbers that we possibly can
two digit numbers okay in the world like
I said about a third of them will be
we'll begin with one and so you can't do
this to Generate random numbers how does
that happen you might ask yes
okay
okay Watch What Happens uh whatever it
was you were doing in Civilization
you were counting something weren't you
you were counting years you were
counting
students in a classroom you were
counting you were counting things
correct level right we do that when
you're counting
how often do you count things and end at
exactly a hundred
when there's 100 things to count but
typically if you're in the it or to 99
if you're in two-digit mode
you're going to be done counting
typically before you get to the 90s
typically
you're gonna be done counting
okay so Watch What Happens
okay
I'm at the number 10. mm-hmm
what percent of my numbers begin with
one
from 10 on no I'm just I just found that
number 10 I have one number what percent
of them begin with a one
if if you only have one number a hundred
a hundred percent okay so okay
let's go to the next number 11.
all my numbers begin with one
until I get to 19. that's right all of
them okay so now watch
finally I'm at 20.
what is I have 10 to 20. what percentage
of my numbers begin with one
10 to 20 well then now 90 90 right begin
with one now I get to 29.
what percent of my numbers began with
one
well now it's uh 30. no I mean sorry 20.
no I'm sorry it's 50. because that 50
percent we're two digit land now right
two digital digit land half your numbers
have begun with one so if you're picking
numbers randomly and people only ever
counted up to 20 half of your numbers
are going to begin with one yeah okay
now let's go up to 30. so now a third of
all your numbers will begin with one
right so now let's get to 40. now it's
25 percent
and 59 now it's 15 percent
only when you get to 99 well the numbers
that began with one be ten percent of
all the numbers
right
only when you get there if you haven't
ever gotten there you will never get 10
of your numbers having begun with one
that is really freaky it's freaky it's
completely freaky and I'm sure people
right now are just like no no no no no
no no
but that is really freaky because you
gotta get there in order for you to be
there but you can't randomize while
you're on your way while you're on your
way that's right yes okay how about this
ever since ever since the year zero the
birth of Jesus
how many years have begun with the
number one
what fraction of them
well until now oh God I I don't know I
see now I'm trying to figure it out
because no approximately approximately
that would be until now because if we
just changed to two so I'm gonna say uh
most of them
[Laughter]
at least
okay because after the year 999
every year began with the number one
until
1999. that's half of them years exactly
and add to that
add to that year one right Right add to
that all the years that were in the
teens that's right okay and then the
year 100s and all the years that were in
100s add that to the fact that half of
the rest of them began with one and you
have more than half of all the years so
if you pull years out of books
you're gonna be way swayed towards
um the number one this is such
freaky math problem in terms of I mean
well a thought process yeah yeah it's a
freaky thought process because you can
never think of it like this but no you
can't randomize while you're that while
you're doing this that's correct amazing
so let me just repeat if you got to 999
then yes in a three-digit world then yes
10 of the numbers will have begun with
one right but for any other number that
you stopped at
because you're picking randomly out of
all of this
the ones will be overrepresented by as
much as a as one-third the average you
can average it and you get a third of
all numbers begin with the number one so
you cannot pick random numbers out of
books or anything else humans have ever
done and believe that they're actually
random because they're not wow or you
can claim they're random and then bet
that
with someone who hasn't heard this
explainer and then you can win money off
of them by what is the most likely uh so
freaky let me just say this
mathematicians
have way too much time on there
thank you
so it's part of the problem of
generating random numbers you can't do
it with stuff we counted because it's
not going to work that I I gotta tell
you man I mean this this is fascinating
when you you really got to take time and
and think about this it is so counter
intuitive when you're thinking about a
randomized process it is
counterintuitive but I I see it exactly
what you're saying once you go in to
pull it out it's no longer it's not
longer because because the process that
generated the numbers favors lower
numbers compared to the high numbers
because everybody's counting through low
numbers wow do you know in the Guinness
book
um for a long while you know the most
common street name in all cities
let me see Elm
I think Main Street you know that but no
you know what it was for the long time
what First Street
okay
you know because if you're counting any
streets right it's going to have a first
street now I'm just it's gonna have a
first uh here we are guys I'm sorry
we're uh you know uh yeah we're from um
uh Planet common sense and um we're just
trying to figure out uh based on our
observations here why you people are so
lazy
um
every single City
the first street is First Street this
First Street there it is it first begins
with the number one that's all that's
awesome if your street has 20 streets
half the streets will begin with the
number one there you go
there it is that's all we got time for
oh man that was good that's good yeah
why did it freak out your brain that is
wild that is wild oh it's pretty cool I
learned this when I was in high school
we had some good math and now I feel
stupid no no I went to a geeky I went to
the Bronx Science which counts eight
Nobel prizes among its graduates so
that's it's the okay I feel better about
myself
all right we gotta quit quit it there
that's been another explainer thanks for
being there chuck all right a pleasure
Neil deGrasse Tyson keep looking up
[Music]